he's like mainstream outlets well I know
Lauren was referenced what in a lot of
the discussions that I was having with
people on Twitter about people in South
Africa who were farmers getting murdered
right she had documentary called
farmlands that yes yeah yeah that was a
weird one where people were getting
angry at me and saying that I was
reciting a racist conspiracy theory I'm
like okay but this is a racist
conspiracy theory that a black person
was talking about in front of Congress I
mean this is a black African guy talking
about it on television in Africa the
problems with farm murders you know and
then there was that guy who is the the
the one who wants reparations who's in
South Africa who's a very controversial
character who was he was kicked out of
one of their organizations for doing a
song singing about killed a boar yes
he's doing it in making gun sounds and
the audience is cheering around along
with this song with gun sounds and it's
about killing farmers the term
conspiracy theory is a tactic that the
press young people use to shut down
conversation if you think about it
Harvey Weinstein was a conspiracy theory
Bill Cosby was a conspiracy theory Kevin
Spacey was a conspiracy theory everyone
knew everyone and everyone kept their
mouth shut
yeah so the idea that a conspiracy
theory is inherently false is itself
inherently false and it's just the way
to stigmatize the school of thought or
an idea that you don't want to talk
about well it's also labeling it as a
racist ideology yeah that's true yeah
you you're immediately rate and they
also it was because of Trump reciting it
Trump had repeated it on television
talking about something in in terms of
the issue with South African farmers
it's but it's one of those things that
we were talking about before where even
if they know that the narrative is not
true it supports what they're trying to
push right so they run with it and so I
just I think the other way if doubling
down I kept posting all these different
things about it I was like well what
about this guy talking about it what
about this what about here's here's some
instances of these murders and then
there's the also the reality of South
Africa in general which is extremely
violent there's a lot of violence and
there's a lot of crime
and some of it has to do with the fact
that these people that are in these
farms are targets because they're out in
the middle of nowhere and whether or not
it's racist that they're going after
them because they're white that's
debatable but black farmers are also
getting attacked it's not simply just
white farmers there is some of that
though but and there's some of them some
of them are going after these farmers
because they're white and this is the
thing that's really disturbing is our
people would people be happier if this
is black people killing other black
people like the Hutu and the Tutsis that
was a big genocide
yes and so yeah it's a problem when
people are being killed regardless of
their race right and tribalism cuts
across racial lines but on the other
side there was also some there's some
legitimate claims to land that was
stolen stolen during apartheid and that
the people who are alive today who might
not have been around during the stealing
of that land are benefiting from the
fact that they're they're living on
stolen land like that's all legitimate
as well so there's legitimate arguments
in terms of like how the land was
procured in the first place and how the
person who's owning it today how they
came to own it so there's it's it's
complex it's very complex but it also
has to do with this culture of violence
in Africa in general right especially
particularly in South Africa where
there's a lot of poverty and you know
these people who are out in these farms
in the middle of nowhere yeah there are
targets people don't what politics from
both sides wants to teach us is that
politics are never complex rights so if
you have your little package and some
things doesn't fit in that package you
don't know what to make of it so you
want to dismiss it because you then
you're gonna have to do the work of
reconsidering your assumptions and
certainly don't discuss it publicly
where you could be misconstrued or
labelled as a racist right and I was
looking at all these people labeling me
as a racist so I was like okay I see
what you're doing but I'm just gonna
keep posting these things because this
is all what I'm saying is all being
substantiated by a bunch of different
people who are also black in South
Africa like this this is a lot of what
this discussion revolves around well and
what Trump's done is had that word lose
a lot of its meaning because like if you
just throw that term around willy-nilly
then at certain point it's like okay to
the boy who cried wolf right and these
and the term is a very broad term it's
grandma's prejudiced and says I don't
want my grandkids you know dating a
black person that's not the same as
advocating genocide and they're both
racist but you can't regard them as
synonymous and one doesn't necessarily
leave you the other you know yeah it's
the fact that racism I mean I think that
racism is probably diminished somewhat
would you agree with that in terms of
like between now and say like when we
were what year were you born 76 do you
think from 1976 to 2018 racism in this
country is diminished enormously down
your arm ously yes I think I I don't
think it's exciting right so I don't
really have friends who are like waspy
white people I can't imagine a situation
when people are hanging out and saying
like racist things and everyone attitude
okay no but I mean I can't imagine them
sitting racist thing everyone looking at
them like they're not crazy right like
it would just be so shocking yeah and I
think 40 years ago that wouldn't be that
uncommon it would happen I think there's
also the the reality of social media is
that there are absolutely real
repercussions for any sort of races out
oh yes anything you say anything that's
any any outburst anything that you say
that in in terms of like this you could
if you're somewhere and you say
something publicly that's racist
someone could tweet that and it will
ruin your life so we could post that on
Facebook and it would ruin your life and
I think that keeps legitimate racists
from being as out with it which reduces
racism overall because I think when less
people are doing it it seems less
culturally acceptable and then people
change the way they think but it's also
it's easier to be racist when you're
only talking to people who are like you
but if you're interacting with people
from all over the world and you're like
okay this putz guy's a putz but he's
also putz like the people I know it's
very hard to maintain that prejudice
when you're seeing people who are acting
similar to you because it's anonymous
behind the screen if they turn out to be
black it's like okay this guy's not
different from me yeah that's it